le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
trouver un emploi à la réunion n'est pas
toujours facile pourquoi alors ne pas
repousser les frontières
maurice madagascar afrique australe nos
voisins sont nombreux dans la zone
depuis quelques années le département
développe avec eux un programme de
coopération et d'insertion une
expérience à la fois professionnelles et
humaines comme en témoigne une elson
valériane ou stéphanie
on va dans la petite rue qui là bas ils
ont laissé leurs familles leurs amis et
leurs foyers à 4000 km de là nelson et
valériane sont deux réunionnais venus
tenter l'expérience de la vie au cap en
afrique du sud
au delà parfait donc on sera comme le
manque de banc donc réservé aux blancs
si nos expatriés découvre l'histoire
locale
ils partagent aussi leur culture en
retour car nelson et valériane
effectuent leurs programmes de mobilité
et d'insertion à l'alliance française du
cap
aujourd'hui une délégation du
département de la réunion est venu leur
rendre visite
le conseil départemental soutient la
coopération régionale via le financement
de contrats uniques d'insertion 17
c'est avec ce type de contrat que notre
de réunionnais ont décidé de changer de
cap pour moi c'était aussi une
opportunité de venir pour améliorer mon
anglais
et puis à lorient c'est vrai que j'avais
impressions autour d'un type en ondes
depuis quelques années donc j'avais
besoin d'une nouvelle expérience puis me
lance un nouveau défi aussi nelson à 45
ans il est docteur en histoire et
photographe professionnel un candidat a
priori sur qualifiés pour des missions
de mobilité mais ce que recherche le
réunionnais c'est une expérience de vie
ce qui m'intéresse c'est vraiment de
découvrir cette société le meilleur
moyen d'être en contact avec le public
vous tous les jours j'apprends discutant
avec les personnes que je reçois et pour
soi pour valériane originaire de petit
il se sait hui est une belle opportunité
professionnelle était au chômage depuis
deux ou trois ans je vais préparer les
concours de la fonction publique c'est
un peu la loterie les concours de la
fonction publique donc postuler pour un
vrai emploi quelque chose de sûre ça m'a
semblé judicieux pour relancer mon
ma carrière mon cv etc les deux
voyageurs sont en mission depuis
quelques mois et déjà laventure semble
prometteuse que ça marche
moi j'ai envie de dire au jeune cory
effectivement il faut sauter la mer on
est à quatre heures de la réunion
c'est vraiment un penny à découvrir ce
cas aussi de l'avenir certainement via
de l'activité on voit que c'est un pays
qui bouge et qui évolue
nous sommes fiers de venir voir
à
ma fille aux manettes bienvenue à pau
payet dans l'est retour sur l'île près
de grand étang c'est dans cette ferme
équestre que stéphanie travaille depuis
des années avec son père elle est ce que
l'on appelle une chuchoteuse une méthode
douce et naturelle pour dresser les
chevaux mais stéphanie va devoir laisser
son activité de côté pour quelques temps
accident la vie ont fait que je me suis
rompu le ligament croisé en octobre et
c'est vrai qu'en termes de reprise c'est
quelque chose qui est assez long et
moins fameux permet du coup de prendre
soin de moi en ayant le temps la
dresseuse va mettre à profit ce répit en
s'envolant vers l'île sainte-marie à
madagascar
là bas elle partagera ses connaissances
sur l'autre activités du domaine
familial
l'agroécologie et la permaculture c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui m'a marqué -
dans depuis mon enfance sur un domaine
familial agricole c'est vrai que voilà
souvent la famille
participent et mes vacances aujourd'hui
je remercie le ciel mais à l'époque
c'était une souffrance je suis allé une
fois dans ma vie à madame mais pas du
tout sur les saintes maries givet en
tant qu'animatrice éducation à
l'environnement donc c'est que j'ai des
idées par rapport à ce que j'aimerais
pouvoir partager échanger aussi
intervenir auprès des écoles pour un
maître peut-être un petit jardin
participatif au sein d'une école après
s'est tourné vers la mer donc ça va être
aussi pour moi quelque chose de
différent d'ici de ce que j'ai
l'habitude de faire et à une belle
découverte aussi pour préparer son
départ
stéphanie a suivi trois semaines de
formation au centre international
d'études pédagogiques
c'est au département qu'elle récupère
avec huit autres volontaires son
attestation de formation fédérales non
tout est prêt pour stéphanie laventure
malgache commencera d'ici fin juin
je suis très sereine par rapport à ce
départ c'est vraiment un vrai plaisir de
de pouvoir découvrir de nouvelles
personnes de pouvoir échanger aussi j'ai
hâte et j'ai hâte d'y être
[Musique]
en 2016 70 réunionnais ont été recrutés
par le département pour des postes en
mobilité des postes à pourvoir à maurice
à madagascar et aux seychelles en
afrique australe ou encore en inde
les candidats peuvent travailler dans le
domaine de l'appui à la francophonie de
l'agriculture de la coopération
institutionnelle ou des médias
les volontaires sont en contrat unique
d'insertion c'est un contrat d'un an
renouvelable une fois
avec un salaire de 1000 30 euros nets
mensuels laisser hui s'adresse aux
personnes qualifiées
âgés de plus de 25 ans en recherche
d'emploi si vous aussi vous êtes prêt à
faire vos valises
vous pouvez consulter le site du
département ou www.cc n'obsède 4 point
fr
[Musique]